thank you good to be here actually I
actually think I am lucky to be alive I
was in the earthquake last week and I
swear to God people on the East Coast
have no perspective of what the
earthquake was really like it was
horrifying I came back the day after the
earthquake I actually said to my friends
here in New York I'm like I was there
man I was in the earthquake and they
were like yes so it was cold here
because there's a certain it's like
there's a callousness it comes with New
York I've been back here two weeks I
didn't realize how quickly the blinders
go up you know they just like they go
right up and you don't even realize it I
mean I was using a payphone two days ago
I'm on the street as I'm standing there
two cop cars pull up onto the sidewalk
four cops get out draw their guns to
investigate the store right in front of
me and my only response was to go not
like they have guns I'll call you back
but who might get out in a second hey
could you speak up there's gunplay on
this long distance take it somewhere
else
I like being back in this city there's a
very interesting city I mean there's
actually a part of town down in the East
Village it's sort of like this 24-hour
round-the-clock homeless Renaissance
Fair now I'm not trying to be
insensitive it's just that there's a
never-ending ecosystem of resellable
garbage in Manhattan and they have the
market cornered now
again I'm not trying to be insensitive
but I had a very humane moment there I
was like a week ago I'm walking in this
neighborhood and this guy comes up to me
he's got no shoes on he's wearing pants
he looks like he's been sleeping in for
weeks and he's holding the board game
sorry okay
and was one of those moments where I
really didn't know what to do who you
know so I'm standing I'm like alright
let's just set him up let's play I don't
want to buy the game but I'll spend some
time with you my friend man also down
there in the West Village now this is I
think of phenomenons going on in most
cities around the country there's this
sort of 20-something neo beatnik retro
bohemian scene going on I don't know if
you're hip to it but you walk into some
coffee shops in most cities and you feel
like you're an expatriate Paris and the
20 you know you're like hey isn't that a
young Ernest Hemingway over there I
think it is hey let's go have a look and
see what he's writing
it's a GAAP application
but I I guess I have just turned 30 so
that means I'm officially have outgrown
my marketing group and I'm trying not to
panic
I actually I think I'm getting a little
older I've joined a gym which is odd for
me I've actually joined a gym this is
the third time I've joined the gym
actually joined the gym once and that
was the last day I went you know I mean
I got diluted I got the 500 hour
membership card I got the card I left I
never went back they understand
I had a guilt card in my wallet yeah but
this time I've been going and I'll be
honest with you for 15 years of my life
I used to smoke I used to drink I did
drugs
you see lard right out of a can
occasionally but that's only if I was
really partying you know but during that
time during that time I never once
thought that I was going to die okay but
the second I set foot on a Stairmaster
okay the second
I'm sure my heart is going to explode
and blood is gonna spray out of my nose
and not only that is that is that a faux
pas at the gym but there is absolutely
no glory and going down on a piece of
gym equipment do you understand if your
heart blows out because you've done too
many drugs and you're having sex with an
underage girl you're a hero in some
circles yeah I mean those circles are
getting smaller but they do exist but
you reap no laurels for going down on a
piece of gym equipment I mean the
humility of that debt I mean could you
imagine that your heart just seizes up
you're on the Stairmaster and you fall
forward and your face smacks down on
that little control panel and the last
thing you see before your synapses
fizzle out is a diode configuration of
fictional hills you know sort of a
visual metaphor for things you won't
accomplish in your life
and I think I think the ironic thing
about that death actually is you know
the guy in the Stairmaster next to you
would not stop his workout to help you
up
give me like I just got my heart rate up
you know I pay membership here in Jesus
what a waste of a Guest Pass but I think
God would be compassionate if you if you
died on a piece of gym equipment just
because it's so humiliating I imagine
you'd actually get up to heaven and he
would be there and he'd say did you die
on a piece of gym equipment yeah well do
you have your card cuz you can workout
here thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]